proposer un petit reportage avec jean
yanne jean yanne qui a été ces derniers
jours à cannes l'acteur ray
semblablement le plus sollicité par les
journalistes il est vrai qu'il a
présentée par son premier film avec
maurice pialat nous ne vieillirons pas
ensemble et il a présenté également le
film qu'il a réalisé lui même qui
s'intitule tout le monde il est beau
tout le monde il est gentil
le festival de cannes pourtant ne semble
pas intéresser particulièrement jean
yanne il en parlait avec une grande
sévérité
écoutez le
that actuellement sur la croisette un
des personnages on en parle plus que
l'on voit le plus ça vous fait quoi
non qu'on voit le plus sûrement pas
parce que je suis plus aux boules
dans l'arrière-pays ou en tout cas dans
la place la plus canon du pays créée sur
la croisette on ne voit pas beaucoup de
festivals nous intéresse pas non le
festival en soi non pourquoi parce que
je
je trouve pas ça intéressant à côté
médaille décoration flash photographe
les starlettes qui stoppe les pieds dans
l'eau et ça c'est quoi pour vous c'est
une foire c'est qu'il n'ya eu ces
guignols c'est n'importe quoi enfin on
le sait bien il ya longtemps que le
festival de cannes le vit sur une
réputation dit dont tout le monde dit et
tous les ans moi je suis ici à cannes
simplement parce que j'ai un appartement
dans la ville 1 et le champion toujours
dur
il n'y a rien d'intéressant ya rien de
bien et les seuls films sur les films
vraiment intéressant et passionnant les
gens les ont déjà vu en projection
privée au festival si vous vous
retrouviez aujourd'hui journalistes à
cannes
quel genre de reportage feriez vous
bajeux se chercherait à savoir qui sont
les gens qui sont là je suis allé tout
ça tout à fait
incidemment dans le hall du palais des
festivals le soir de la présentation du
film de pialat parce qu'on avait une
émission parallèle et qu'on fait j'ai
peur tellement de raisons d'assister à
cette première en étant déguisé en étant
en smoking parce que le film pour si sa
carrière et que et que les choses
publicitaires qu'il faut faire pour
l'annoncer peuvent se faire en dehors
des festivals mais j'étais dans lol dans
le coin je pouvais pas entrer toute
façon parce que j'étais en bout de
gilles et et j'ai regardé la tronche des
types qui rend près dans l'assisté à ça
et je chantais j'en connaissais pas un
seul j'ai jamais vue ni dans la radio ni
dans le cinéma je sais absolument pas
qui c'est
je crois que il n'ya que les que les que
les amis des amis à qui on refile les
cartons pour aller dans ce festival